In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 25th, on which we commemorate the return of
the relics of the Holy Apostle Bartholomew.
On the 25th of the month, we celebrate the translation of the relics of the Holy and
glorious Apostle Bartholomew.
After having proclaimed the name of Christ in various places, the Holy Apostle Bartholomew
died by crucifixion in Armenia on the 11th of June.
The faithful of the area placed his body in a lead coffin and hid it in urbanopolis.
As healings were constantly brought about by the saints' holy relics, crowds of Christians
went to receive the relief of their ills, both bodily and spiritual.
Seeing this, the pagans, servants of the devil, were seized with fury and grasped the first
opportunity to get possession of the coffin, containing the precious relics, and throw it
into the sea, along with the remains of four other martyrs, Papian, Lucian, Gregory, and
Achaus.
The coffin, however, miraculously floated and brought the saints' blessings to many places
through the presence of his body, crossing the black sea and the helispont.
It passed through the Aegean and the Adriatic to come to a final stop on the coast of the
island of Lepadi.
The bodies of the four other saints, which had escorted St. Bartholomew on the whole voyage,
stopped in various places according to the good will of providence.
Papian at Amalia in Sicily, Lucian at Messina, Gregory at Kolymenos in Calabria, and Achausia
at Ascalos.
St. Bartholomew appeared in a dream to Agathon, Bishop of Lepadi, who got up at once and
went to the beach there, with wonder finding the lead coffin.
He cried out, O Lepadi, whence have we such a treasure and such glory, dance with joy, exalt
to receive such a blessing and cry out, welcome, O Apostle of the Lord.
The local people disputed among themselves about whose would be the honor of bearing the
Holy Relics on his land and building a church.
But all their efforts were in vain, the coffin remained as though stuck to the beach until
the Bishop, after a revelation had it drawn by oxen to the place determined by the will
of God.
At that moment an eyelid closed to Lepadi, moved a distance of seven Stadia under the
action of divine power.
Agathon had a church built there in honor of the saint, where miracles abounded.
During the reign of Theophilus, the iconoclast, the island was captured by the Arabs and abandoned
by its inhabitants.
Having learned of this, the governor of the town of Benaventus sent Christians from Amalfi
to take the Holy Relics, before which he and the Bishop walked together and had them placed
in a church, where many of the faithful were able to receive the grace that flowed from them.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.